Let's go next to our call or from the a three
Oh three area code.
Who's calling from three Oh three today.
Can you hear me all right, David?
Yeah.
Who's this?
This is Patrick calling from Colorado.
Hey, Patrick.
What's going on?
So I'm wondering if you saw the, uh, Sean
Hannity Deblazio interview last week?
No.
Wow.
How was it?
Oh, horrifying.
Just horrible.
In what sense though?
Because Hannity was asking his weird questions
and attack questions or because the Blasio
was,
oh yeah.
Well, I mean de Blasio did.
Okay.
I think his position is not something I'm
fully on board with.
Right.
Just honestly, just the way that like Sean
Hannity is definitely one of the worst when
it comes to a beating, unable to ask questions
that are even grounded in Maria.
Yeah.
Um, but
I have to say though, I haven't mentioned
that, I've mentioned this before and I don't
know if you've heard me say this or others.
It's probably new to other people who are
watching this or listening to this.
Sean Hannity is absolutely deplorable and
disgusting.
I, I, he has a horrible history with his real
estate investments of effectively being like
a slumlord type dude.
He, his politics are disgusting.
His attack interviews are just vial.
Personally, he is super nice every time I've
seen him in person at different radio events,
he's way nicer than a lot of the left left-wing
via a media people.
There are left wing media people that a lot
of people in my audience probably really like
in terms of their politics who are disgustingly
vial people who react to you saying hi as
if you are just like a piece of dirty gum
on the bottom of their shoe.
Hannity is super nice and he'll stick around
and take pictures with whoever and talk to
whoever.
I have to give him credit for that even though
his politics are disgusting.
Oh yeah.
And do like not saying anything about the
guy personally, but like it really is just
like his inability to oh yeah.
But yeah, like the, the [inaudible] the thing
that uh, Kyle Kalinsky actually did cover
it just the other day, but only a small segment,
uh, about taxes.
And the thing is like, even to this day, Sean
Hannity says 70 cents out of every dollar
when he's talking about the, uh, income tax.
And it's just insane to me that you can not
yet like the marginal tax rate.
Yeah.
W we have a lot of people, I would say they
don't understand it, but with Hannity I think
you're suggesting he's deliberately and I
think that's probably the case.
Yeah.
I have no doubt that he is.
And like even in my personal life, I've had
some people on the right, um, with blamed
how income tax works to these people on multiple
occasions.
Yeah.
But something about just like, I don't know
if it's just their inability to comprehend
a nuance or something, but
inability and the inconvenience of comprehending
it.
I think it's a combination of the two.
Yeah.
And of course that nuance comprehension goes
into every single issue you can possibly bring
up.
Absolutely.
Patrick, thank you.
Appreciate the call.
I'll check out that interview.
Will do.
All right, take care.
Thank you.